[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'une collision entre
deux aliments qu'ils ne se rencontrent
pas souvent et haricots sont utilisés
dans les desserts là c'est pas quelque
chose de bizarre et son regard dans le
monde en asie
c'est pas nouveau tout mélanger les pois
chiches et le chocolat ça semble pas
naturel de prime abord il ya des gens
qui vont trouver ça étrange non humains
sucré c'est quoi ça mais une fois qu'ils
goûtent ils sont surpris ils sont
surpris souvent ça peut sembler assez
surprenant peut-être douteuse même pour
certaines personnes mais faut vraiment
faire l'essai pour voir que ça
fonctionne
nutritionniste autre essai conférencière
stéphanie côté façon oumou sucré depuis
quelques années l'idée de faire du home
ou sucré est venu en m'inspirant de
blogs des missions européennes ou
américaines
il y en a dans les magazines y en a même
sur instagram et autres donc j'en ai
vraiment une multitude de recettes qu'on
peut essayer soi même à la maison c'est
tout le temps facile à faire avec des
ingrédients généralement faciles à
trouver aussi puis vint ça coûte trois
foires et donc vraiment de recette
gagnante
le pois chiche c'est tellement doux au
bouquet ça se mélange bien avec d'autres
ingrédients et au final la légumineuse
belle passe presque incognito pour que
sa recette soit bien lisse
stéphanie fait bouillir les pois chiches
avec du bicarbonate de soude pu regarder
juste une petite pression la fourchette
l'homme puis je vois pied des jeunes
face et l'a écrasée crémeux une purée
qui va être super laisse au mélangeur
qu'en comparaison ici c'est un projet
qui était qui ne pas vous y est je le
sens le gène de résistance sous la
fourchette d'un mélangeur par une pure
et légumineuses mais la mettre en
version sucrée ça je trouve l idée tout
à fait séduisante pour faire manger
davantage de légumineuses au quotidien
toute la famille
pour faire une sortie des saveurs du
cacao plus même quand je fais un
chocolat chaud je mets un peu d'eau dans
la casserole
je la fais bouillir jeune et mon cacao
que les saveurs ressorte le cacao se
disent beaucoup mieux personnage ajoute
mon l'imprimé au teint grisâtre le biais
d'élémentaire canadien recommande de
manger plus de végétaux donc le who's
who crise ça devient de plus en plus
facile d'en manger
moi j'utilise du sirop d'érable j'ai mis
à peu près un tiers de tence de sirop
d'érable pour une boîte de pois chiches
donc ça me donne mars est au complet
la vanille c'est vraiment pour le goût
elle se mérite tellement bon aussi à la
saveur du chocolat on pourrait le mettre
non je trouve qu'un petit plus avec
l'aragon bien ça donne au final une
tartinade chocolatées qui est cinq fois
moins sucré que du nutella du commerce
donc ça a beau être sucrée mais ça passe
vraiment avec une super belle valeur
nutritive
donc c'est peu sucré c'est riche en
protéines serré chantait brel imandt
r600 défaut le mot sucré on peut le
manger avec des fruits comme 30 est par
exemple on peut même les tartiner sur
des rôtis des bigots on peut la manger à
la cuillère honnêtement je tombe sur
vient d'avoir avec lui on a tellement
d'une conception du pois chiche avec
l'un et puis un petit peu de citron puis
on est notre famille de goût de textron
tous est délicieux c'est vraiment bavé
sur le marché on trouve des homos
sucrées dont se destine racines une
jeune entrepreneur comme base elle
n'utilise pas les pois chiches sur le
marché il ya très souvent les mêmes
ingrédients dans plein de choses était
dommage et c'est important la variété et
j'y crois j'y crois fortement autant
pour eux l'équilibré que pour
l'environnement aussi c'est pour cette
raison qu'est ce qu'elle préfère
utiliser comme base différentes variétés
de haricots
donc là on parle d'art au noir pour ce
qui est des mets sur mon cas et d humus
au chocolat haricots blancs le hummus à
l'érable dans les ingrédients donc
là-bas ce sont les haricots soit les
lois soient les bleus voilà on a de la
pâte de dattes qui vient en plus agité
des films on a le secret de coco on a
tout à fait chocolat sirop d'érable un
petit peu de sel un peu d'huile de
canola donc ça reste relativement simple
les femmes parce qu'on a des protéines
qui nous viennent des haricots pilote un
petit goût sucré mais c'est pas trop
sucré parce que je regardais le tableau
puisque 2e à 4 grammes de sur la saveur
du ratio quand même pas beaucoup
personnellement moi je les mange niçois
en collation où des jeunes et c'est là
où j'ai besoin d'un peu de protéine un
petit quelque chose là pour me soutenir
ça peut être mangé sur des torses ça
peut être mangé sur des gaufres des
crêpes trempé des fruits des dans une
autre possibilité c'est de le mettre
dans un griot dans un yogourt surtaxe
sur le social
oui les brevets il resterait plus je
pense que ça al'avantage de démocratiser
encore plus le houmous de le faire
connaître à ceux qui ne le connaissaient
pas ça al'avantage aussi de faire manger
plus de ligue 2 peut être aux enfants et
à ceux qui veulent les apprivoiser
tranquille
[Musique]